hello there Americans split on the gun
control walk out the right splits on
free trade and we'll check the mailbag
and do many other fun and amusing things
I'm Ben Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro
show
so he hadn't noticed I'm just in one of
those moods because I watched The
Avengers infinity trailer and all I can
say is does every character from every
movie have to appear in one movie should
we just make like isn't that called life
when we're all in the same movie
together but I guess that's the way
we're gonna do movies now so I'm doing
movie mashups I'd think Sleepless in
Seattle in a contagion should be in the
same universe
Shifa meg Ryan finally finds some Hanks
horrible disease okay we'll get to
actual news in just a second but first I
want to say thank you to our sponsors
over at Skillshare so if you don't want
to end up like me trying to figure out
exactly how bad movies mash up with one
another then you need to make it resume
better right you need to actually put
more skills on your resume that's where
a skill share comes in skill share is
the best way to ensure that you're
constantly updating and increasing your
skill set that's what they are for
they're an online learning platform with
over 18,000 classes in design business
technology and more you can take classes
in graphic design social media marketing
illustration mobile photography you name
it they've got it we've here at the
office taken social media marketing
classes with them in search engine
optimization classes with them I took a
watercolor class with them Skillshare is
there to keep you learning and thriving
again everybody's gonna be moving around
jobs nobody's been working at the same
company for 30 years hired break it's
all my employees
you'll all be gone in the next three
months but after that you'll be looking
for a new job which is why they're all
on Skillshare
right now go to Skillshare dot-com slash
Shapiro and you get two months of
Skillshare for just 99 cents that's
right Skillshare is offering my
listeners right now two months of
unlimited access to over 18,000 classes
for just 99 cents to sign up go to
Skillshare comm slash Shapiro that skill
share comm slash Shapiro and you get
those two months for 99 cents right now
Skillshare comm slash Shapiro once
you're subscribed you're gonna want to
keep going because there are just too
many numbers they're just too many I
mean they're just too many classes that
are great there's just too many classes
that are great go to Skillshare comm
slash up hero and check it out alrighty
so the the fallout from yesterday's gun
control walkout continues and I'm
getting tons of the emails from kids who
feel like they were essentially
discriminated against at these walk outs
I just got one from a kid who wrote to
me and said that he wanted that he
wasn't intending on being political at
this walkout he waited until people
brought out the gun control signs then
he brought up the Gadsden flag and he
was immediately shut down by his school
he's immediately told he had to put it
away
and this is not rare I'm getting again
tons of these emails on a
minute-by-minute basis at this point
it's it's pretty it's pretty astonishing
and pretty shocking and demonstrates
once again that there are too many
teachers across the country who think
that they get to propagandize and use
their students as these propaganda
outlets now not every teacher is in
favor of this in fact there many
teachers who are not in favor of this
and there are lots of states like
California where you have to be a member
of a teacher's union in order to teach
and if you are a member of a teacher's
union you are expected to toe the party
line and one of the close family friends
of ours growing up was a guy who is a
member of the teachers unions because he
had to be and he would constantly get
the updates from the teachers unions and
they were all left-wing updates this is
a coordinated effort from the top and it
really is quite awful one teacher has
actually been suspended for questioning
the gun control walkout
her name is Julian julienne Ben Zell and
she says that she opened up the
discussion in her classroom about the
politics of the protest and she was
subsequently told to stay home on
Wednesday because the administration
didn't like it here's what she had to
say on CBS 13 local others in Northern
California boolean benzoyl says she
never discouraged her students for
participating in national school walkout
but she did question whether it's
appropriate for a school to support a
protest against gun violence if it's not
willing to support all protests it's the
best example I thought of at the time if
a group of students nationwide or even
locally decided I want to walk out of
school for 17 minutes and go in the quad
area and protest abortion okay and she's
of course exactly right if the students
decided to walk out and protest abortion
they would have no capacity to and none
of the teachers would sponsor it right
but because this is a national gun
anti-gun walkout all the students were
expected to walk out I've gotten notes
from students who say that they wanted
to stay in class because they didn't
feel like creating a hubbub they were
just gonna stay inside the school and
they've actually been getting notes from
teachers you know threats of suspension
for staying in the school during the
walkout so it's it's really astonishing
stuff and it demonstrates once and for
all that something really nefarious has
happened in a lot of our public schools
and that is our public schools have
become a tool for the left-wing
propaganda okay they really have
especially in in classes like social
science I know what what they used to
call history but now they call social
science you know those classes our
social studies rather those classes I've
been taking over
by the left and this is why so many
parents are pulling their kids out of
public school and putting their kids in
private school they're saying you're not
even doing a good job of insuring that
my kids are getting an education but you
can certainly ensure that my kids get to
walk out a class and miss class in order
to make a political statement that has
nothing to do with their education
because of course these kids can't vote
their parents can if their parents want
to do something they are free to lobby
why these kids should be leaving school
in order to do what they're doing that
is beyond me it doesn't seem like it
makes any sense at all but again these
teachers are political actors and
teachers unions are political activists
schools of thought that's what they do
if you look at just how teachers unions
work the way they bargain with the state
is they are basically democratic tools
and that was predicted long ago by
Olivia von mises in his book bureaucracy
talking about how any employee of the
state ends up being a propaganda outlet
for the state and this is certainly true
with regard to teachers unions because
the way it works with teachers unions is
you want to support Democrats because if
you elect Democrats Democrats will then
give you a cozy union payout and that's
the way that it works in the state of
California or the CalPERS system for
example is bankrupting the state where
teachers have signed union contracts
with the state they give them these very
very rich pensions and these pensions
are trillions of dollars unpaid
trillions of dollars at least hundreds
of billions of dollars and the state
lies about it and the state says well
don't worry we're gonna pay out we'll
never have to tax people additionally
because we're just gonna have certain
growth rate in the CalPERS fund none of
that's ever going to happen but again if
you're a teachers union then this is all
great for you all you have to do support
Democratic policies and get Democratic
politicians elected with all of the
union dues that the teachers pay in and
the state mandates that you pay your
union dues in order to work save this
guild and this guild is mandated by the
state you have to work for the guild in
order to work for the schools and then
the guild take some of your money and
pays those politicians to keep that that
system going keep that rig system going
and those politicians get to push
legislation and all they ask in return
is that the teachers unions push all of
their ancillary causes and that's what a
lot of these teachers unions are doing
it's really shocking and appalling and
again most of these students who are
walking out have no political bent one
way or another it's not like most of
these students who are walking out are
passionate about gun control the vast
majority of students who walked out
probably have no idea anything about gun
control they probably don't know any
facts about gun control in fact there
are some students who are walking out
just because they want to walk out and
go do stupid things like this is film
from Chicago students walked out and
they proceeded
to trash a Walmart for no reason so
these students charged into a Walmart
and they upturned all the stalls I like
the security guards laughing about it
well done security guards but it's just
a monster who the fact that young people
sometimes are stupid this does not mean
that all young people who walked out
don't have any political knowledge some
of them do some of them are politically
active some who oppose my position some
who support my position some who are in
favor of Second Amendment rights some
who are in favor of gun control but to
pretend that all of these students are
the wisest and fairest of all beings
they're the elves in our little morality
play of middle-earth it's just it's
foolish and it's not true at all
especially when you look at what
actually happened in Broward County so
this video came out yesterday and it
really is shocking it's video from
Broward County of the sheriff's deputy
right this is the on school site deputy
and he obviously first of all does not
look like he should be on school site
security one of the big problems that
you see when you talk about in school
security is very often these are rented
cops very often these are people who
could not pass a physical these are
people who could not run a block without
losing their breath is not everybody
who's a school deputy obviously but it
is true for a certain number of them and
it is important that you have some
people who actually are in good shape
know what they're doing
this guy I don't feel bad ripping on
because you'll see in the video that
they hear the gunshots he takes off on
his little golf cart to go over to the
area where the shooting is happening and
then you'll see in the video he stands
around and does nothing for 20 minutes
here's what it looked like when the when
the Broward County Sheriff's Office
released the tape so you can see him
it's a silent video so I'll narrate it
you can see him and Scott Peterson the
BSO school resource officer who looks
like he's maybe in his 50s and he drives
it over to the area where the shooting
is happening and then he proceeds to
legitimately just standing outside the
building he's just standing around
outside the building doing nothing I
mean it's an amazing thing right and he
there's there's part of this video that
we cut
out where he can actually see students
fleeing the building through another one
of these doors does he charge in does he
do anything no and according to the
Broward County Sheriff's Office the
orders that are given to their officers
are that if there is an act of school
shooting you are supposed to engage
we're not supposed to stand outside so
to talk about how these guys were told
that they were supposed to stand outside
how that was the policy of the
department that was not true so there's
there's one problem with the department
with regard to policy and that is this
policy that says we're not going to
arrest anyone because we don't want to
increase the arrest statistics on
students we want to show that our
students are doing really well and so
we'll just pretend that no crime is
going on but this one looks like it was
on Scott Peterson and not on the Broward
County Sheriff's Office per se
nonetheless this is not stopping the
agenda from rolling forward mika
brzezinski over at MSNBC she says the
NRA should be sued and things have
changed at least in the state of Florida
the NRA with their inflammatory ads and
threatening ads should be sued okay well
on what grounds do the NRA be sued in
order for you to sue somebody you
actually have to have legal grounds
there actually has to be a legal purpose
for the suit otherwise we'll be thrown
out but according to so many people on
the Left lawsuits happen when you're
angry at something so you don't like the
NRA says you get to throw it out can the
NRA was not responsible for the shooting
one of the most astonishing things I saw
yesterday was Code Pink calling for an
end to funding for JROTC on campus
they're saying well we don't want
campuses militarized we need to stop
funding JROTC there are three kids who
were killed were members of JROTC and
one of those kids actually threw himself
in front of bullets to save other kids
well this idiot cop was standing around
outside doing nothing one of these
students a fifteen year old he ran out
there and he tried to stop the shooter
already got in the way of the bullets he
saved his students he died in the
process and code pink is saying she got
rid of JROTC again the big problem with
evil is that evil cannot be prevented
simply by legal mechanisms usually evil
can only be prevented by good people it
can only be prevented by good people
doing the right things and unfortunately
the left is not ones who recognize the
real possibility of human evil they're
just not interested in recognizing that
possibility it's pretty it's pretty
horrible so meanwhile president Trump is
is embracing this new bill the school
safety bill and the school safety bill
really does not have much gun control
attached so everybody on the Left is of
course very upset about that they
thought that President Trump was going
to break the impasse on on school
on gun control that of course was never
really going to happen
so in just a few minutes I'm gonna talk
about what exactly is in the school
safety bill and we'll talk about that
but first I want to say thank you to our
sponsors over at Dollar Shave Club so
and get up in the morning you look you
look at yourself in the mirror and you
see that you need to shave but all you
have is that rusty old razor and you
just forgot to run to the market to pick
up new razors and they're too expensive
anyway well this is where Dollar Shave
Club comes in okay Dollar Shave Club
gives you everything that you need in
order to be clean and and and wonderful
for the morning okay they are more than
just razors by the way they deliver
everything to you that you need to look
smell and feel your best shampoo body
wash treat placed everything come
straight to you you never have to worry
about running out of it at home because
it's coming to you on a regular shipment
basis they have the best razors I've
ever used you get an amazing
high-quality shave every morning from
the Dollar Shave Club executive razor
and the true hero of course is the dr.
Carver's shave butter which is just
fantastic
he's right here under the jawline is
just terrific another must-have is the
Dollar Shave Club delivery experience
because again you're always getting
caught up short on this stuff you are I
know you are oh yeah I am I mean if
you've had enough Dollar Shave Club I'd
constantly be looking around saying oh
no I'm out of toothpaste again I forgot
I'll pick up tomorrow morning but the
meantime yuck hey that happens all the
time well no you don't have to do that
anymore now it all comes directly to
your door for a mind-blowing experience
join Dollar Shave Club today and for
just $5 with free shipping you get the
six blade executive razor plus trial
sizes of shea butter body cleanser and
one wipe travel ease then you can keep
the blades coming for a few bucks more
per month get yours at
dollarshaveclub.com slash pen that's
dollarshaveclub.com slash men again you
get that trial size of everything
including the magical butt wipes over at
dollarshaveclub.com it's lush men
there's a reason they're they're such a
fast-growing company it's because
everybody wants in and you can get in
right now at that special deal over at
dollarshaveclub.com
slash men check them out and get
everything that you need all righty so
the here is what's in these school
safety bills so it passed the house it
has the support of a wide variety of
Senators and it doesn't do anything
about gun control per se but it does do
some things about school security so
there is no parallel measure pending in
the Senate right now they're trying to
push gun control in the Senate of course
but that's not going to happen this bill
is instead a bill that doesn't allow
that that is seeking to increase
security
schools so the the it does not allow any
of the funding to any of the funding
that's going to be given for school
security be used for arming teacher or
other school personnel the the White
House wants that restriction lifted but
the bill itself is filled with some
measures that are designed to ensure
that that this stuff doesn't happen
again or at least that there's better
security on campus is funded by the
federal government so the school safety
bill let me bring up the actual
provisions of the bill right here so the
school safety bill is let's see it
passed by an overwhelming margin by the
way in the House of Representatives it
is not yet been brought brought up as I
say before the Senate again all the
people I'm left a very upset because
they think the only measure that can be
taken here is going to be gun control
but it steers clear of the demands of
gun control advocates it is the stop
school violence Act it provides 50
million dollars a year for a new federal
grant program to train students teachers
and law enforcement how to spot and
report signs of gun violence it also
develops anonymous telephone and online
systems where people could report
threats of violence and authorizes 25
million dollars for schools to beef up
security in ways such as installing new
locks metal detectors and panic buttons
okay so this is a good start
ok White House Democrats overwhelmingly
supported the school safety sorry the
House Democrats overwhelmingly supported
the school safety measure according to
the hill but they say this doesn't do
enough Republicans say this is only
beginning this is the first steps and ok
these should be the first steps
obviously I think that the states should
actually take precedence here I'm not
sure that the federal government should
be leading the way on any of this stuff
in the first place but I think that it
is it is pretty clear that these that
the school the school safety bill should
pass with flying colors through the
Senate ok meanwhile this is another
story that that I think is worth talking
about Huffington Post has done something
pretty amazing so Huffington Post is the
is obviously a very left-wing outlet and
the deputy opinion editor of The
Huffington Post is a person named Chloe
angle okay Chloe angle triumphantly
tweeted out the demographics of people
they have published this year it just
shows how crazy the left has become with
regard to their politics of
intersectionality here's what they say
month two of HuffPost opinion is almost
done this month we published 63 percent
women including trans women 53% writers
of color our goals for this month war
less than 50% white authors Asian
representation that matches or exceeds
the u.s. population more trans and
non-binary authors and then say we also
wanted to raise latinx representation to
mattre exceed the u.s. population we
didn't achieve that goal but we're
moving firmly in the right direction
making the improvements we made took
work no doubt about it we all tapped our
networks and made moves to expand our
collective rolodex I check our numbers
at the end of the week because it's easy
to lose track or imagine you're doing
better than you really are and the
numbers don't lie the numbers also don't
tell the whole story about disability
geography socio economics and more but
the work is not owner Asst and it's
definitely not impossible if we can do
it every other opinion page can do it
too and if you have an op-ed to pitch
here's how you can do that so what I
love about this is the deputy opinion
page editor over at The Huffington Post
doesn't make any case with regard to the
quality of the submissions over at
Huffington Post there's nothing to be
said here about how great Huffington
Post quality is instead all they care
about is the racial breakdown of the
people writing which used to be called
racial quotas and we're obviously Latin
X sorry not latinx okay this is all
supposed to be a guarantor not of
quality on the page but instead a
guarantee a guarantor of of demographic
equality but what's really funny about
this is that if you're actually gonna be
demographically equal on the Huffington
Post page maybe about 70 percent whites
it would be 50 percent males it would be
90 percent straight
it would be almost 0% transgender it's
this point three point three percent of
the US population is transgender but
they're not trying to do that diversity
only exists for those who are
marginalized groups and those
marginalized groups must now become a
majority according to the left all of
this is incredibly stupid and has
nothing to do with the quality of the
work on these pages so pretty
astonishing stuff okay meanwhile
President Trump continues to forge forth
on his anti free trade program and this
is obviously not good policy Tucker
Carlson made the best case on this last
night there there are a bunch of folks
who are on the who are on the Trump side
of the aisle who are trying to make the
case for tariffs who are trying to make
the case for protectionism my problem
with tariffs and protectionism obviously
is that they believe in the power of
centralized government here's Tucker
trying to make his strongest case for
technology and and trade being the
downfall of American civilization it's
not a horrible case but I don't think
it's a convincing one either lawmakers
in
both parties for example have heartily
embraced self-driving vehicles and drone
delivery of packages it's all impressive
technology but what would be the effect
on employment has anyone asked that
there are more than 3 million
professional truck drivers in this
country it is the most common job in the
majority of American States more than 90
percent of drivers are men
thanks technology many of these men are
about to lose their jobs it's a lot of
unemployed Americans that's a lot of
broken families Washington is not
worried at all about this lawmakers and
business leaders assure us that those
truck drivers will be just fine they'll
find something else to do something
better in fact with higher pay and maybe
they will but keep in mind our leaders
said the very same thing about
manufacturing jobs 30 years ago ok so
this is a what Tucker points out here is
I think a generalized argument can
always be made in favor of centralized
government what he's saying is there's a
group of people in the United States
they are uh no lower educated white men
basically these are these are people who
are living in the middle of the country
and people who are working in non
technology jobs these are people who are
working on lines these are people who
are truck drivers and these people are
going to be hurt by technology and trade
and we have to do something for these
people but the implication is and
throughout this monologue was that these
people if they're not taking care of
number one that they are going to not
get married they're not going to stick
around for their wives and children that
they are going to start acting in worse
ways there are a couple of assumptions
embedded in Tucker's in Tucker's the
notion here that I think are problematic
so what problem number one is he seems
to suggest that poverty and lack of job
opportunity cause immorality I don't
actually think that's the case I think
that moral people tend to act morally
whether they are poor or whether they
are rich there are lots of terrible rich
people there are lots of wonderful poor
people there are lots of people who make
a lot of money in their jobs and there
are lots of money and they lots people
make very little money and all of them
go to the same church so when Tucker
suggests that you know people who are
earning a lower wage you're suddenly
going to not stick around for their kids
I'm not sure I see the correlation there
or at least I'm going to resist the
correlation the other thing is that this
is not really a case for tariffs it's
not really a case for shutting down
traders shutting down technology so I'm
not sure what Tucker is actually arguing
for
I agree that a lot of this stuff is a
problem I agree that we have a problem
with people who are not law lawyers or
doctors people who don't have higher
education degrees and what do we do with
them as the does the technology develops
and they lose their jobs what do we do
with those folks but the answer is not
to cyfle the technology tucker seems to
be making the case against self-driving
trucks
okay but you could have made that exact
same case against cars back in 1910 you
could have said they're a bunch of
wheelwright so we're going to lose their
jobs this is true with every
technological change every single one
they're a bunch of people who lost their
jobs over at 80 when people stopped
using landlines there are a bunch of
folks who lost their jobs when when
dial-up internet went away there are a
bunch of people who lose their jobs when
you when any new technology is developed
they're a bunch of people who lose their
jobs the question is are a consummate
number of jobs created on the other end
are there more jobs that are created on
the other end or just as many jobs
created and by the way that isn't even
really the question the question is does
quality of life go up for the vast
majority of Americans every time there's
a technological change because the goal
of an economy is not to create jobs the
goal of jobs is to create an economy
meaning the purpose of a job is to
create a product or service someone else
wants to buy it is not the job of the
economy per se or the government per se
to ensure that anyone has a job if you
get that polarity backwards you end up
the communism where everybody has a job
but they're not producing anything
anybody wants centralized government is
not the answer here now there was a
piece that I referenced a little bit
yesterday I want to go through in a
little more detail here regarding
tariffs there's a piece over at the
Journal of American greatness the
Journal of American greatness was an
outlet devoted to president Trump's
purported philosophy and it's kind of
lost some of its luster because
President Trump doesn't have really a
coherent philosophy but there was a
piece there that was taking on something
I said on the show about free trade and
this piece is by a guy named Spencer
Morrison who's a law student and
editor-in-chief of the national
economics editorial which I've never
heard of and here's what he says he says
McKee's titled why Ben Shapiro is wrong
on free trade now let's just make
something clear my perspective on free
trade is backed by essentially 100% of
economists there very few economists who
believe in tariffs when I say very few I
mean that if you if you polled actual
economists the number of economists who
would dismiss free trade in favor of
tariffs that number is very close to
zero so here is what this article says I
think it's worth discussing in detail so
Morrison argues in favor of tariffs and
it begins with
analysis of a three-minute segment of
video from this podcast in which I
talked about the flaws in tariff based
economics I specifically talked in that
segment about the fact that trade
deficits don't matter about the fact
that if you have a trade deficit with
your grocery store your grocery store is
not screwing you nor are you being
screwed by your grocery store and if we
buy more product from China than China
buys from us that does not mean that we
are losing to China China just has a
bunch of dollars it has to spend which
then has to invest back in American
bonds or back in American businesses or
an American real estate now obviously
I've done a lot of work on tariffs on
the show but there's a new argument that
Morrison presents that I think that you
should know about just so that you know
what you're talking about when you talk
about free trade so first Morrison sort
of misrepresents my argument he suggests
that I think trade deficits are an act
of good I've never said trade deficits
hard act of good they're not an act of
good they're not an act of bad they're
just a thing right you sometimes have a
trade deficit with your grocery store
sometimes you're a contractor to your
grocery store and you have a trade
surplus none of that means that anything
inherently bad or good is going on as
I've quoted before Thomas Hall says this
in general international deficits and
surpluses have had virtually no
correlation with the performance of most
nations economies Germany and France
have had international trade surpluses
while there unemployment rates were in
double digits Japan's post-war rise to
economic prominence on the world stage
included years when it ran deficits as
well as years when it ran surpluses the
US was the biggest debtor nation in the
world during its rise to industrial
supremacy
became a creditor as a result of lending
money to its European allies during the
First World War and has been both a
debtor and a creditor at various times
since through it all the American
standard of living has remained the
highest in the world unaffected by
whether it was a creditor or a debtor
nation now Morrison is this author who
claims that I have called Trump a
flip-flopper on fair trade which I never
have he's been very clear that he's anti
free trade but here's the central
argument that's made and this is the one
that I think we should spend some time
talking about just so that you know the
arguments that are being made against
free trade and why they are wrong so
here's what Morrison says he talks about
comparative advantage
comparative advantages this idea let's
say that I Ben Shapiro I am great at
making this podcast but I also happen to
be very good at growing oranges I'm
pretty good at it not like the best but
pretty good right and let's see that I
can even make I can even grow origins
better than my local grocery store but I
am the very best at making this podcast
so every minute that I spend not growing
oranges is a minute that I spend on the
podcast and every minute that I spend on
the podcast is a minute I spend not
growing oranges should I spend my time
doing
Kaster should I spend my time growing
oranges the answer of course is that I
should take all the money I'm earning
from the podcast and go buy some oranges
at a cheaper price the time value right
the money the monetary value of my time
is higher doing the thing that I am best
at even if it means that I'm buying from
somebody else who's specializing in an
area where I'm still the best but it's
just not the best thing I do and I'm
better at the podcast and I'm a growing
oranges therefore I should spend more of
my time doing the podcast than growing
oranges even if the second-best guy
growing oranges is not as good as I am
at it right he should specialize in
growing oranges I should specialize in
podcasting and then we should trade
services for one another I should give
him a subscription for $9.99 a month and
he should give me a bag of oranges right
this is the idea of comparative
advantage so here's what Morrison says
his comparative advantage is an elegant
theory but too often is domain-specific
it only works when certain preconditions
are met for example capital must be
immobile for the theory to apply okay
meaning that Mike I can't just take my
capital and go buy a an orange farm in
Brazil now Shapiro ignores this crucial
limiting factor and applies comparative
advantage to just about everything
this is his root error for example
comparative advantage suggests the key
to getting rich is to specialize
production
regardless of what you produce that is a
country with comparative advantage in
growing soybeans should focus on growing
more soybeans while a country with
comparative advantage and manufacturing
semiconductors should focus on
manufacturing more semiconductors in
either case this supposes the relative
wealth will correlate with the degree of
specialization as opposed to the
complexity of their production this is
objectively wrong so what he says is
that if you're a country the producer
semiconductors are gonna be richer than
a country the producer soybeans there's
only a there are a bunch of problems
with this so first of all it is
important to note that countries don't
just make soybeans or semiconductors
right they make lots of products
countries are not individuals countries
are broad amalgams of individuals all of
whom are in different industries right
so this guy says well you know this guy
makes the the obvious point that if you
grow on bananas you're gonna make less
money than if you make computers this is
obviously true ok but of course
countries that develop higher profit
sectors are gonna have higher growth
rates and of course the decisions that
you make now are gonna have impact on
the future development of industry so
this is his second argument he says ok
so granted that a country that grows
bananas makes less money than a country
that makes semiconductors so if you are
a banana growing country comparative
advantage would suggest you keep
bananas but that means that you're never
going to become in the semiconductor
making country therefore what you should
really do is you should tariffs
semiconductors you should put a tariff
on floor and semiconductors and then you
should grow your business and
semiconductors from the inside ok this
neglects a few points has neglects a few
points first of all you cannot tell
which sectors of an economy are likely
to be the most profitable right this is
something called the what he's talking
about here is a term called path
dependency path dependency is you made a
mistake you decide to grow bananas and
now you're sucker own bananas forever
even if it would be more profitable for
you to move in to move into making
semiconductors but this assumes that you
can't just stop making bananas and start
making semiconductors it assumes there's
no bank that will lend you money if you
get a computer education degree to go
make semiconductors right this assumes
there's no mobility in the economy which
of course is not true and if the
government were to say listen we're
going to tariffs semiconductors we're
gonna tax all the banana growers and
take all their money and we're gonna use
it to subsidize semiconductors who's to
say the government knows which industry
is going to grow fastest when government
introduces subsidies into an industry it
usually makes that industry little more
profitable but it doesn't end up picking
the industry that always works it is a
very important point ok let's say let's
take Trump steel tariffs Trump thinks
the steel industry is very very
important so he's going to tax all of us
that's what a tariff is and then he's
gonna take that money and he's gonna
give it to the steel industry it's the
same thing as a tax in a subsidy that's
all the tariff is the tariff is I'm
gonna pay more for my car so that my
money will go to the steel industry
that's Trump saying he thinks the steel
industry is particularly important but
how does Trump know the steel industry
is particularly important how does he
know the future of what technological
development is going to look like now
there's a notion that you have to
protect the steel industry from foreign
predation but why why I mean for
security reasons you could but there's
no indication that security is the
problem here what's happening here is
that Trump likes steel in a way he
doesn't like other industry so heat
things steel ought to be protected but
what does Trump know that the economy
doesn't this is the whole reason
centralized government fails one guy at
the top does not know as much about how
products and services should move as the
entire economy as this diffuse hands of
the market you and I choosing on our own
what we want to buy and what we want to
sell right you can't tell which sectors
are going to be the most profitable and
the government is actually far more
likely to lock in particular path
dependency right now your path dependent
on steel in the United States or
dependent on semiconductors then to spur
future economic growth and also most
market Lakhan is self-correcting we
develop new products on a routine basis
that are different in kind from the
products that preceded them so the
argument for path dependency that you
pick a winner and now you're stuck or
you pick up an industry now you're stuck
it doesn't really hold the in the sort
of example that people use when they
talk about path dependency and trade
there's the example of your QWERTY
keyboard right there's this myth that
there are two types of keyboard there's
the QWERTY keyboard that everybody has
on their on their laptop and then there
is the Dvorak keyboard that was invented
at the same time as supposedly as faster
hey number one there's no evidence that
it's faster number two the cost of
moving away from the QWERTY keyboard and
towards something else have to be taken
into account when we say why don't we
switch to a more efficient keyboard in
other words there are costs a you could
say we should have picked the Dvorak
keyboard that would have been better but
now they're cost attached to switching
so the argument is well then maybe
government should have subsidized the
Dvorak keyboard for example but that
doesn't make sense because the
government didn't know the Dvorak
keyboard was better and if the market
had known that Dvorak keyboard was
better than it would have picked the
Dvorak keyboard but that's not what
happened right so if we could see the
future at the bottom line is that people
who are in favor of tariffs think that
certain industries are more important
than others and that government can see
the future and has to protect those
industries but that makes no sense in
1947 the smart money in the United
States would have been unsubsidized anon
subsidizing manufacturing taxing all
other industries in the United States to
subsidize manufacturing and that
would've been totally wrong in 1947
according to the Bureau of Economic
Analysis Manufacturing represents a
quarter of all GDP production in the
United States finance represented 10.3%
agriculture represented 8 percent those
would have been the three industries to
dump money into but if we attacks
agriculture and Finance to finance
manufacturing that would've been stupid
by 2016
Manufacturing had fallen to eleven point
seven percent of GDP and Finance
represents in 21 percent agriculture
represented 1 percent so if we had had
the government picking and choosing
winners and losers we would have put our
money in the wrong place this is why
central planning usually fails Paul
David of Stanford University writes from
the foregoing and maybe seeing that a
proper understanding of path dependence
and of possibilities of externalities
leading to market failure is not without
interesting implications for economic
policy but those are not all
the sorts and glib conclusions that some
critics have alleged must follow if one
believes that history really matters
namely the government should try to pick
winners rather than let markets make
mistakes
quite the contrary public policy could
try to delay the market from committing
to the future inextricably before enough
information has been obtained about the
likely technical or organizational legal
implications of an early
precedent-setting decision in other
words government picking and choosing
winners actually ensures past dependency
it ensures market lock-in impoverishing
private sectors through tariffs in order
to dump money into non competitive
industries actually impoverishes your
country as a whole economic flexibility
requires that the government should not
impede the free flow of capital within
industries and what about the idea that
if your banana in producing economy
you'll never become a software producing
economy there's no proof of that
private lenders will pay the freight for
new industries right the United States
again used to be a manufacturing economy
and then it became a service economy
this happens it happens all the time so
the central argument here just doesn't
work in favor of tariffs and I think
that that is worth noting ok so I have a
lot more to talk about including an
insane retraction that was pushed out by
Pro Publica about a trump nominee in
just a second first you're gonna have to
go over to Daley wire.com and subscribe
so for $9.99 a month you get a
subscription to daily wire when you do
you get the rest of this show live gets
been part of the mailbag I'll be
answering all your questions right now
it'll be magical you can go check it out
remember at daily wire comm for $9.99 a
month
you also get Michael Moses show live
Andrew Clavin show live and with the
annual subscription you get this the
very greatest and beverage vessels the
leftist here's hot or cold tumblr it is
just phenomenal you will love every
second of it so check all of that out or
listen later over iTunes or SoundCloud
YouTube please subscribe please leave us
a review we are the largest fastest
growing conservative podcast in the
nation
so moving on from trade policy the Trump
administration is still having high
turnover there was a tweet earlier today
from reporter talking about somebody
inside the the Trump administration who
said they were expecting large moves
inside the administration something is
coming we don't know what it is which is
not a helpful report from the reporters
but the turnover is very high well one
of the people who's been elevated by the
turnover is the new CIA nominee the new
CIA director nominee whose name is Gina
Haslam we talked about this yesterday
about how Senator Rand Paul tore into
Haspel suggesting that she had overseen
torture in foreign lands and it turns
out that is not true okay he was basing
that off of a ProPublica article that
was printed yesterday they had to issue
this retraction the story said that
Haspel a career CIA officer who
president Trump has nominated to be the
next director of Central Intelligence
oversaw the clandestine base while our
Abu Zubaydah terrorist was subjected to
waterboarding and other coercive
interrogation methods that are widely
seen as torture the story also said she
mocked the prisoners suffering in a
private conversation
neither of these assertions is correct
and we were tracked them it is now clear
that Haspel did not check take charge of
the base until after the interrogation
of Zubaydah ended so this is obviously a
pretty egregious error but it shows that
people on the left are really invested
in trying to suggest that trumps
nominees are awful awful people also
they're very invested in the narrative
that there's a lot of chaos at the White
House now there is some cast at the
White House there's no question there
are a lot of people in the White House
who are wondering what in the world is
going on there are a series of competing
rumors yesterday they were pretty
amazing there was one that chief of
staff John Kelly was going to be leaving
there was one that NSA the the NSA
general McMaster was going to be leaving
there was one that the VA secretary was
going to be leaving the administration
keeps trying to tamp down these rumors
but it's hard to tamp them down when the
President of the United States is
constantly ripping his own cabinet
members on Twitter and also when he says
things publicly about how he likes to
watch them fight like like that guy from
Godzilla let them fight he likes to
watch his cabinet officers jockey for
position there was rumor that Scott
Pruett over the EPA was on the hot seat
there's where the Ben Carson is on the
hot seat there's a rumor that that
Bryan's inky is on the hot seat so
they're a bunch of rumors they're like
half his cabinets gonna be gone but
Sarah Huckabee Sanders yesterday was
saying don't worry McMaster is not going
anywhere of course they were saying the
same thing about Gary Cohn five seconds
ago
here is Sarah Sanders when she tweeted
out she said just spoke to POTUS and
general HR McMaster contrary to reports
they have a good working relationship
and there are no changes at the NSC okay
that's not convincing considering again
that they've said this about every
person who has ever left the
administration Kellyanne Conway came out
said they keep recycling rumors but the
rumors have no Verity to them here's
what she had to say they won't cover
policy they cover personnel they won't
cover principal they cover palace
intrigue and they keep on recycling
rumors and stories constantly that have
no basis in fact they think they figure
hey if a stop clock is at least Right
twice a day
eventually I'll get this right so if I
predict a whole year in advance so once
I was on thin ice silence I was going to
go and they do a year later I could just
recycle those clips where people said
the president has full confidence in X
and six months a year later it changes
this president has every right to put
the team around him that he thinks
aligns with his vision his values but he
is the one who controls the tiny the
cone tone and content of all substantive
and personnel decisions so obviously the
president has the right to do whatever
he wants on personnel that's really not
the question the question is is it good
that there's this much turnover well
some of the turnover is good like Rex
Tillerson leaving the Secretary of State
is good and there's so much turmoil at
the administration though that that was
like the sixth biggest story of the week
that the Secretary of State was booted
out of office by the president normally
there'd be a pretty big story instead
that is downgraded to to the lower end
of the spectrum
listen if Trump wants to make some moves
he should rip off the mandate he should
make his moves you should be done the
prolonged feeling of chaos is not good
for the administration they have some
things to do and it's not worthwhile to
have them dragging this process out over
long periods of time I recommend to the
administration that they just get on
what they need to get done because it's
otherwise it's it's putting too much
pressure on the American public to go
along with the daily reality show that's
happening at the White House I know a
lot of president Trump supporters don't
seem to care that's fine but the
American people do care not because
they're sitting around waiting for the
next tweet to fire somebody but because
they do want a feeling of steady
leadership at the White House now Obama
was not a steady leader but the media
ensured that he felt like a steady
leader even though he was not right
there they would continue to put out
this vision of Obama as cool as a
cucumber guy which I don't think the
evidence is quite there for but
there
not therefore Trump right they're going
to up the amount of cancer Trump has to
be twice as cool as anybody else has
been in the office and I don't know that
that's actually going to happen okay so
you know what let's take some actual
time with the mailbag today we'll go
back to things I like and things I hate
at the very end of the show but let's go
straight to the mailbag today so get in
your questions right now we'll just jump
right in all right we begin today with
Hendrix so Hendrix says if you just has
to rock music why does your show start
with an electric guitar so I don't
detest all rock music Hendrick number
one number two my show starts with an
electric guitar because that is the the
electric guitar is being played by the
brother of the founder of the company
one of the founders of the company and
we didn't want to pay rights to to
actually buy musical cuts to use here so
instead we just had a guy play two notes
pretty awesome right okay so Jay James
says hi Ben I don't know if you've ever
been asked about these particular
questions but I'm sure it's highly
likely your background in debate and
evidence-based arguments as well
established when it comes to the
evidence concerning the existence of God
is the citation of an accepted religious
tome of Authority enough or is a
considered conjecture and/or not
substantial enough could a rational
argument based on biblical evidence hold
up in a rational legal court of law if
the idea of God were put on trial quota
or rather would ardent atheists like Sam
Harris or Richard Harrow Dawkins find
any substantive reason to find your
arguments compelling enough to consider
the religious position as tenable or the
minds of such intellectuals closed off
to the possibility of God to the point
that any argument made by a believer
would be seen as reaching and circular
such as the arguments for the existence
of God made by Descartes and his
meditations treatise in short is there
any actual evidence in your mind that
would hold water and a legal proceeding
or can faith in law and out reasonably
coexist without one co-opting the other
in one way or another
Jim okay so Jim I will say that I think
that logical proofs of God tend to whack
yeah I think you can make a logical
argument for God but that's not the same
as a logical proof of God because God
hides himself in the universe right this
is the basic religious tenet God is a
incorporeal he doesn't manifest himself
at least in Judaism right there's no
idea of God actually taking corporeal
form in the form of Jesus for example so
in Judaism and in this true in Islam as
well and even in Christianity where God
has not taken human form for the last
two thousand years there is a feeling
that God hides himself in the universe
that God is something you have to
discover making an argument for the
existence of God is possible in fact
I've recommend
in a book by Edward fazer philosophy
professor / Grove City College in
Pasadena who who has written a very good
I think it's a Grove he may be a
Pasadena City College night guys
he's written a very good book up five
proofs of the existence of God and he
has an Aquinas proof and he has and he
has a he has a proof from Pascal and he
has a bunch of different proofs and some
of them I find pretty compelling but at
best you can make a probabilistic case
for God it's very difficult to make an
onion evidentiary case for God because
any piece of evidence in favor of God
can also be interpreted against God so
if you say look at the beauty of the
universe the Atheist will say right that
beauty of the universe was created
through sheer accident or there are
multiple universes if you say God made
this universe in a particular way and
the chances of the universe being made
in this particular way to sustain human
life are really really really unlikely
then folks on the other side a theist
will say well what if there are multiple
universes what if there are parallel
universes or what if God ruled that what
if time is endless and gods rule and and
the dice have been rolled of a bajillion
times right you know in other words
these arguments come to a standstill the
best argument for God that I believe
exists there there are two arguments for
God that I think are compelling and
again I don't think they are provable
but I think that are compelling one is
that there is a system of logic that
undergirds the universe that is the
basis for all human thought in science
right science is the idea that you are
discovering under the you are
discovering consistent rules in the
universe that pre-exists your being and
there's an objective truth that would
exist regardless of your presence on
earth and so the religious person says
that's proof of a designer that these
rules exist and the more you study the
rules of the universe the more you are
shocked by the by the genius that
created them now atheists will say there
was no genius that created them right
this is all accident you're just a speck
of dust moving through the universe on
the meaningless rock you're a ball of
meat moving without sentience through
through life right you have a basic idea
that you're here but you don't really
have control right which brings us to
the second argument in favor of God and
that is the argument of free will the
argument that you have something that
allows you to supersede your own
biological necessity and make choices
every single day and that all of
civilization is based on this premise
and then in fact all of a co6 thought -
is based on this premise because until
very recently both most atheists
believed in the concept of free will if
you go back to the French Revolution and
and Enlightenment thinkers even people
like Laplace are then a bunch of folks
who are who are
Enlightenment thinkers were atheists who
believed in at least a very contains
notion of free well now folks like Sam
Harris I think are really consistent on
this right Sam says there is no such
thing as free well and he doesn't try to
make the compatibilist argument that is
made by some advocates of non free well
where they say well you know everything
is biologically determined but at the
same time there is a sense of free will
because there is chaos built into the
system that's not free will it's just
chaos built into the system actually
agree with Sam on this I agree there are
only two real positions on freewill
right there's the hard freewill position
there's a bility to choose otherwise and
then there's the and then there is the
deterministic position which is that you
in this situation right now have no
choice but to behave as you are behaving
if you believe in free will which is an
experiential thing if you believe like
Samuel Johnson right that it's it's tana
logical that let's not argue about
freewill it's here if you believe that
it's very difficult not to believe that
there is at least some force in the
universe that you just do not understand
and that cannot be explained by all it
cannot be explained away by physical
laws and that at least gets you to a
place where there's a supernatural
element to life that we just don't
connect with or understand and then you
can move beyond there - is there a logic
to that supernatural presence that
unites creation right so those are the
arguments in favor of God again their
arguments I don't think that they are
completely provable and I don't I'm not
gonna pretend that I can prove to Sam
Harris or mantle hunty or anybody else
on the on the Atheist left that that God
exists I just don't think that it's
possible to prove God exists and I think
that that's one of God's points right as
a believer in God I think God does not
want you to be able to prove God exists
if I could provide you proof right now
here and now that God existed then
obeying God's law would be the easiest
thing in the world because you wouldn't
have a choice maybe the argument would
be God exists and then if I could prove
to you just through sheer evidence that
the Bible was given by God it's the is
the unadulterated Word of God then you
would not have a choice the creator of
the universe has in order to do things
you must do these things or the
punishments that God provides engine in
the in the Bible will come true
but I don't think God wants us to behave
that way I think God's whole purpose and
creating the world was to create beings
in His image meaning they have free will
and the capacity to create and choose
people who believe by the way they have
free will and the capacity to create and
choose as my friend Jordan Peterson
likes to say people who are trying to
generate order from chaos these are
people who find fulfillment and purpose
in life it's very difficult to build
either an individual or collective
system of meaning on the basis of your
meatball floating through space Kyle
says what do you think the world would
be like if there was a second
she's on earth as intelligence as humans
well you know I think that we'd have
conversations with them and I think we'd
have to take into account common
interests frankly I do think that there
are such differences between people that
we are not separate species but there's
enough for us to talk about to get past
our differences men and women are
different enough that having
conversations that way is hard enough as
it is adding a second species would
would make things even more difficult
Jewell says how can we innovate music
only one and genre is correct in your
case classical you can innovate within
classical music right Stravinsky is very
different from Beethoven Bartok Bartok
is incredibly different from Brahms
there are certain rules that you can
imagine abiding by and still work within
those rules in fact I think most great
art is created within the confines of
particular rules I think most great
novels are written in complete sentences
I think most great novels are written
using typical rules of human English in
fact I think that they're they're a few
that break the rules but most of the
anomalies that break those rules at
least know where the rules are right if
you read ken kesey right who's a fan of
breaking grammatical rules or if you
read or if you read a Clockwork Orange
in which an entire new language is
developed all of that is based on
knowledge of the rules and then specific
breaking of the rules to a particular
end a feeling of chaos a feeling of
newness a feeling of generating language
beyond our typical language all of that
can be broken but that's not what rock
does rock is not people who learn the
rules and then decided in order fashion
to bend or break them it's a bunch of
people who don't know the rules who play
who hit the who hit they drum on two and
four and who play three chords and
that's not breaking the rules that is
not only not breaking the rules it's not
even it doesn't even acknowledge that
the rules exist and so you actually ends
up with a much more primitive form of
music than anything that was developed
in the Classical era Daniel says what
are your thoughts on elderly firearm
ownership should the restricter rules
for people over a certain age to
purchase firearms no but I think that
you should be able to apply if people
are have dementia to have those guns
removed from people's homes I'm not sure
that age is a good argument that our 80
year olds capable of having a weapon if
you're a law-abiding citizen and you
need to defend yourself I don't see the
problem with you owning a shotgun you
know that said if you are senile then I
do see the problem with you owning a
shotgun Jim says I've heard you use the
phrase the proof is in the pudding and
shortly after I heard Michael Mills
point out that the original saying is
the proof of the pudding is in the
eating do you think this is a targeted
correction and how does it feel to be
corrected by best-selling author Michael
Knowles
thanks love the show well James I can't
believe that
put you in the mailbag but I will say
that just because the original saying
was the proof of the pudding is in the
eating does not mean that the proof is
in the pudding is not the modern saying
or at least the bastardization of that
saying so it's less a correction than I
think in the day and an addendum by
Michael Mills and Michael has corrected
me on occasion about things like writing
words and books that apparently was a
complete waste of time but it does not
feel good to be corrected by Michael
Knowles listen I've had to pay him more
money than I thought humanly possible
right he works for me means I pay my
salary I lost a bet to him our
relationship is not going well
Veronica's his Haven I had an idea for a
youtube series when I talked about
struggling with depression anxiety I
hope to use my experiences to help
others realize they can reach out to
their families and communities with
their struggles and get the help they
need my only worry is that if I admit to
some of the darker problems I faced I
could lose my second Amendment rights I
haven't ever attempted suicide and has
been years since the worst of my
depression but I live in New Jersey and
gun laws are tough to begin with my
fiancee also worries that this may
affect his ownership rights when we
lived together
am i worrying over nothing or am i right
to be hesitating well I don't know what
the current status in law is in New
Jersey but typically you have to prove
that someone is a current danger to
themselves or others not that they once
had issues with depression ten years ago
five years ago two years ago you
actually have to have hard proof that
somebody is a threat to themselves or
others you don't sound like that's the
threat I think that your series sounds
like a wonderful thing I think there are
a lot of people out there who are
suffering with depression and anxiety
who don't even know what it is they are
suffering with and a little solidarity
along those lines would be a perfectly
wonderful thing jordan says Haven the
Libertarian Party today posted on
Twitter that they support the students
and their political works from the
walkout yesterday why would the
libertarian party support gun control so
I haven't seen the post so I'm gonna
hesitate - a tribute to I'll take you
out your word okay
if what you are saying is correct
assuming what you're saying is correct
that's because the libertarian party is
ridiculous
in the ran Gary Johnson for presidents
of the United States twice hey this
party's in disarray it's really
frustrating because as a conservative /
libertarian I would love to see a vital
and working libertarian party but this
is the party that trots out John McAfee
at their at their events and then also
trots out a naked guy wearing an Iron
Cross tattoos so I'm gonna go with their
crazy at least the party Pete says hi
Ben I'm with you on the immigration
question let's keep those that are
behaving in accordance with American
values and customs playing the tape
before it concerns me however say the
wall does get built what happens then
does the black labor market disappear
how our labor law is going to change
what benefits our guest worker is going
to be entitled to
it unreasonable for me to have doubts as
to the ability of the US government to
administer such a program effectively
really you're never wrong in doubting
the ability of the US government to
administer any program effectively but
the idea here would be that there
probably be guest worker programs that
are h-1b visas but this is why I don't
think the wall is the be-all end-all I
mean the whole point here is that half
illegal immigrants in the United States
are people who overstayed their legal
visas so that means that we really
should be focusing on ensuring that we
are enforcing the laws that are already
on the books I'm fine with a wall I'm in
favorable law but I don't think the wall
is gonna solve the problem Levi says hey
Ben I've been particularly been
following your show for the last few
years but just recently subscribed
though he's part of my tax refund
because what's more American than that
my question is regarding taxes in the
latest tax reform my sister and
brother-in-law are big liberals and at
that last family get-together we're
saying that without the inheritance tax
the rich could and would put all their
money in a trust fund and then claim a
lower tax bracket I wasn't sure of
logistics so I had to debate them using
all of their premises is this true are
there loopholes that are now possible
without the inheritance tax thanks for
all use okay so the inheritance tax is
ridiculous when the inheritance tax is
is disgusting I already paid tax on that
money so when you get income you pay tax
on your income then the money goes into
your estate right if the estate accrues
money right if it accrues capital gains
then you pay capital gains tax you don't
pay income tax the rate on capital gains
in income is not the same now there's a
case to be made that you should pay the
same tax on capital gains as you pay on
income that's actually not a terrible
case but the solution to this is not to
clawback half the money that you already
paid taxes on I mean every year I'm
paying an enormous sum of taxes and then
I'm taking the leftover and I'm putting
it into savings for my kids and by the
way when I put that money into a trust
fund for my kids the bank is taking that
money and borrowing against that money
the bank doesn't just leave the money
sitting in a lockbox somewhere the bank
actually takes that money and lends it
out at interest to other people who are
starting businesses so all of this is
economic ignorance on the part of these
folks yeah the whole point of working
hard one of the reasons that you work to
make a profit is that you can take that
money and pass it on to your children I
would be supremely pissed if I did not
have the ability to dispose of my money
as I saw fit at the end of my life
Samuels has been I will be in DC for
vacation soon what in the historic city
meets the opinion means the standard of
can't-miss in your opinion want to make
the trip worthwhile and would love your
input so I think that the National
Archive is fantastic you actually go see
the actual original Constitution of the
United
States and Declaration of Independence
which is super cool I think that the
Supreme Court is really fun to visit the
Smithsonian museums are of course really
neat you should walk through the Capitol
and check that out because it's kind of
neat to see that this isn't some sort of
you know faraway place that these are
actual people working on the ground who
are just normal human beings it's cool
to visit the White House
you know I've honestly I visited the the
kind of private part of the White House
more than I visited the public part of
the White House but there's there you
know the White House is a really neat
place to visit all the typical sights
that you see I really need the
Washington Monument is great the
Jefferson Memorial is great the Lincoln
Memorial is great there are so many
sites in DC it's it's really a
tremendous place to visit I just wish
that they would decentralize it and
destroy it I think one of my big
problems with DC is that I think you can
tell whether a country is run well or
not by whether the buildings that are
government buildings are nicer than the
private buildings in DC they are and
that's a problem I like countries where
I like areas what like state buildings
are usually worse than the the private
buildings in the same city I think
that's the way it should be I think we
should decentralized in Washington DC
and make people live in their home
districts and then vote from their home
districts and this is what the internet
was created for my Chelsea says Haven
Trump is nominated unit Haspel to
replace Mike Pompeo the biggest
criticism of hers from working a secret
prison in Thailand where at least one
terrorist was waterboarded and then she
subsequently ordered evidence of the
waterboarding destroyed so again this
was retracted today by Pro Publica what
is the justification for using torture
on terrorist suspects does it violate
their human rights so the justification
for using torture on terrorist suspects
is twofold one terror suspects are not
accorded protection under the Geneva
Convention as I explained yesterday the
Geneva Convention was designed to ensure
that money - not money that was designed
to ensure that soldiers stayed in
uniform right if they got out of uniform
they're no longer protected by the
Geneva Conventions you go back and watch
the Great Escape
and you'll see this is a major issue
right as soon as people try to escape
the prison and dress up the civilians to
escape they're no longer protected by
the Geneva Conventions and this is a
major risk for them this is for a reason
you don't want people dressing up as
civilians going into civilian areas and
using those civilians for cover it gets
more civilians killed one of the
purposes of the Geneva Conventions is to
prevent that from happening so
terrorists should not be treated as
members of an enemy army they should be
treated as terrorists second of all is
torture useful well was for Khalid
Sheikh Mohammed right we waterboarded
him a bejeweled
times and we got some good information
from him about the about al-qaeda and
its leadership structure and all the
rest so there's a really strong open
debate going on about whether torture
works or whether it does not I'm not
gonna I'm not going to pretend that I
think that waterboarding isn't a form of
torture it's not the form of torture
that does permanent damage but it's
certainly torturing the person
psychologically do I think that it's
called for in certain circumstances I
think probably but I think there's a
good argument to be made on the other
side I mean there's some people who say
the torture doesn't work at all I find
that dubious that's the argument anyway
Jade says do you use an e-reader like a
Kindle or you do prefer physical book so
I tried a Kindle I tried it I tried it I
tried it I prefer physical books I
strongly prefer physical books one of
the reasons for that is number one I
just like the feel of a book in my hand
I like the that I like to be able to
turn the pages I feel like I'm making
progress in a book one of the things
that drives me nuts about Kindle is that
it tells you percentage of the book that
you've completed not page numbers which
is annoying to me and then beyond that I
have another problem which is I can't
use a Kindle on Sabbath and I get a lot
of reading done on Shabbat so if I'm in
the middle of reading a book on Kindle I
can't read it on Sabbath so I have to
buy the physical copy anyway josh says
I'm a senior at Stoneman Douglas my
government teacher recently asked for a
conservative and the liberal student to
go on Trevor Noah I offered to be the
conservative any tips for if I go on
well number one just research the facts
all the way up and down and make sure
that you know Trevor Noah may try to
suggest that you care less than you're a
liberal friend and if he does then what
you should say to him is listen Trevor
I'm one of the people who is at the
school you don't say you don't get to
call into question my sincerity on these
issues right you need to we need to have
an open debate about these things and
that has to start with people stopping
questioning other people's sincerity and
it's not just me right I think you
should say to Trevor no you've been here
ripping on the NRA ripping on Dana lash
suggesting that she doesn't care about
dead kids and all the rest of it I am
one of the kids who's victimized I
believe a lot of the same things that
Dana lash believes and I don't think
that makes her uncaring and I think that
you need to stop that if you want to
have a valuable conversation like this
is a good valuable conversation we're
having conservative liberal Trevor Noah
right we're all having conversation
together not doubting each other's
motives if you can't grant that same
capacity to so many other people in the
political sphere we're never gonna get
anywhere I would start with that point
first of all I should do it second of
all go totally viral so you should
totally do that if you're on Trevor Noah
show car says hey Ben if you had a Carl
if you had an opportunity to overhaul
the public education system what would
you do well curriculum changes would you
make and would you remove or include any
courses of study do you
there should be an early separation of
students in two different tracks likes
for students that plan to go to college
versus to trade schools straight to the
workforce big fan of York so yes I do
think tracking should start earlier I
don't think it should start you know one
sir now you don't even started until
you're in grad school so certainly by
the time you're in college you should be
tracked now the way it works in Israel
is that you start getting tracked at age
17 which makes some sense to me
curriculum changes you need a strong
course in Western Civ I don't just mean
you read about the history of Western
Civ I mean you actually have to study
the philosophy of westerns have you have
to take the Bible seriously and Plato
and Aristotle seriously and Aquinas
seriously and you have to take the the
Phyllis LC riously and you have to take
the English enlightenment seriously I
think a good course of Western
civilization be useful in fact the book
I'm writing is essentially that it's
basically a primer on Western
civilization so I hope that that will be
helpful ok time for a quick thing I like
and a quick thing I hate and then we
will break for the weekend so thing that
I like today how we've been doing books
on socialism there's a book called the
God that failed which is really a
compilation of various essays from great
thinkers people who many of whom used to
be socialists and then decided that was
stupid the best one in the in the
collection is by Arthur Kessler who's
also the author of a fantastic book
called darkness at noon it's a novel
it's about 100 pages maybe and it's it's
an amazing book it's basically about a
Trotsky figure who's captured by his own
Revolution and thrown in jail and his
experience before he's executed so it's
you know light reading but the book to
God that failed is is definitely worth
reading check that out ok time for a
quick thing that I hate all righty so
the quick thing that I hate today is the
Vanessa and Donald Trump Donald John
Trump jr.
are divorcing and the media are making a
huge deal out of this right this is a
big deal because of course he is a
public figure they've released a joint
statement
apparently Vanessa didn't like being in
the public eye they have five children
so it really is tragic here's what they
said after 12 years of marriage we have
decided to go our separate ways we will
always have tremendous respect for each
other and our families we have five
beautiful children together they remain
our top priority we ask for your privacy
during this time that's the way you
should handle this although you know
obviously I wish that they would work to
put it back together I'm not in their
situation but it's just you know
obviously divorce is a terrible terrible
thing what's what's really gross there's
so many people on the Left who are
celebrating this Oh John June you're
getting what he deserves yeah this is a
family I wouldn't be excited if the
Obamas divorced right I that'd be
terrible they have children I don't like
it when people
when bad things happen to people even if
you don't like them politically and it's
just their and their children involved
particularly there's nothing to laugh
about when it's Hollywood celebrities
who are married for three months then
they get to force then you can laugh at
them but if they have children then it
becomes a tragic situation already so we
will be back here on Monday with all the
latest I'm Ben Shapiro this is the Ben
Shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Mathis Glover executive producer Jeremy
boring senior producer Jonathan hey our
technical producer is Austin Stevens
edited by Alex and Garo audio is mixed
by Mike Carmina hair and makeup is by
Joshua Oliveira the Ben Shapiro show is
a daily wire for word publishing
production copyright floor publishing